my name is forgive I work in live in
Norway
I'm originally from Russia and next hour
I'm going to talk about how to write
front end in f-sharp and I guess even
non-technical person just when when they
read the title of the talks they may
suspect that this is somewhat esoteric
mmm area and they they might be right so
I think we will begin a little bit from
from a motivation like how how I came up
with a reader's talk I'm going to
explain it but I won't also to begin a
question with the question to you as an
audience what brought you here to to
listen to this talk who is actually
doing front-end development using
f-sharp 100 this is mine okay then I
guess I'm maybe like two main types of
interests one is my curiosity broaden
horizons and I have great respect for
that because a lot of interesting
projects and developments I can start it
from people trying to sing differently
all maybe you have some practical ideas
actually you you you have some front end
in mind which you may be not happy with
the current currently recommended stack
and then you want to explore some more
so who is mainly driven by you know
curiosity just to learn to read hear
about something you I guess majority who
think that there might be some practical
implication of what what you are going
to hear yeah minority yeah
so I'm actually mmm
well when I first heard about if be
approached function programming approach
the front end I was also as a drink
about out of plain curiosity but lately
I was just driven by practical means and
I will trying to convince you that
actually it's not far
going from being curious to do something
in practice to our product just to give
you idea about our domain I work on a
project for a Norwegian Broadcasting
Corporation the closest match in UK
would be BBC it's a state organization
broadcasting TV and radio programs and
we working in a group which take care of
distribution of media files metadata so
actually I'm a back-end developer which
gives another question okay why back-end
developer should care about user
interface I mean how dare I actually
stand speak here about user interface if
I'm if I'm a back-end developer I think
it's easier to answer to this question
nowadays when we developers work much
closer to operations actually we don't
split we don't we are no longer screened
from what's going on in the operations
this is just one of our walls I took a
picture a few days ago and it's not just
a central control unit I think we have
plain surf walls if you just moving
along the floors where developers
sitting this is our floors walls which
show monitors diagrams states of our
services so we actually we we need to
care about what's going on all the time
because if you have a news clip which is
not published then it becomes you know a
little crisis after five minutes so we
need to know what's going on and of
course the best way to quickly give the
information it's to visualize it with
graphs with scholars make it easy to
consume so any developer cares about
quality and now nowadays more than
before of course before all this care
about quality but we were not probably
so directly exposed to it as we are
during these days I speak about quality
there is a great talk by David Evans
utilizing quality which are
recommend to watch everyone no matter if
you attest the developer back-end
front-end maybe I know developer at all
David go through various cases where not
only software related most of them I
should not source related when lack of
proper presentation of information led
to consequences sometimes quite fatal
and this Ryan London it's probably it
fits to quote one of his examples he was
showing how most people would travel
from Paddington to Lancaster Gate I came
from Oslo yesterday and that is
Paddington
of course we are this is the st. James
Park but let's say I need to travel
shorter distance to Lancaster Gate so
I'm probably would take tube to not
nothing he'll gay gate yes and then
transfer and then Lancaster Gate if you
look at geographically correct London
Tube map we will get some slightly
different picture because you see that
where we are okay
yeah passing from Lancaster Gate so
actually we going Ness homes all the way
to the west and then we going back to
the east you might suspect it actually
it's easier to walk and if you google
you will find that actually you it
squawk it's a quicker to walk so this is
just example of you know how easy to be
misled by improper information and
everything that is just very exceptional
example no you belong I actually found
the research which states that about 30
percent of passengers misled by the
famous Tube map so about every third
passenger actually travels wrong so this
was actually motivation for me as a as a
team member to start looking and how can
I contribute to visualize better what
I'm doing I another thought about myself
as a as a back-end developer okay I need
to step in and do something better about
this services which are taken care of
and then it's not a question about like
doing or not doing using the face
and then you know how we can develop it
and then of course past which is
recommended for very many reasons is
that two masters tml JavaScript and CSS
and you know it's not I wouldn't say
that it's not always an option but it's
a it has its cost for somebody who is
not doing user interface like every day
I would compare it with recommendation
for any composer to rent professional
recording studio of course there are
recording studios professional future
for good reasons and they cost about now
hundred times to rent them to do music
production at home but there are great
music production that made at home and
the whole world knows them so actually
to become efficient to reach out with
results of your creativity you don't
really need to you know go somewhat
established path you can investigate
some other passes which keeps you
efficient so and speaking about
front-end there are actually several
criterias there are things to consider
if you want to choose your development
style of course nothing can be wrong
with choosing JavaScript and CSS but you
know it's about learning curve how much
time can you invest it about efficiency
also you may want this UI code to be
better integrated in your current code
base to be better integrated in your
current development ecosystem and last
but not least actually quite many of us
appreciate strongly typed languages who
appreciate strongly typed programming
languages Oh almost
who doesn't appreciate from the
controllers yeah we are yeah yeah yeah I
mean it's a I mean you have your reasons
there with JavaScript which works it's
one of the main popular programming
languages
yeah so it's not so long to learn
JavaScript CSS assuming that you feel
efficient and then it doesn't consume
time to go that past but we see that in
dotnet world developers has been
successfully exploiting asp.net tranberg
and there are in other platforms there
are other choices and recently
webassembly became quite popular and
here on this conference i think there
are at least couple of talks about
blazer it's really no it's very hard to
get accepted to do talk on this
conference but like when two talks are
about blazer it shows level popularity
of this among developers and there is a
functional approach with several option
several choices like l which was
specifically developed for to write
front end its LM equivalent on dotnet
platform it's a char fable you have
reason ml total strip and you have more
and the majority of these functional
choices say compiling to JavaScript
so why functional approach I guess the
main reason to take functional path
actually it's the same reason why
developers often choose function
languages to implement back-end its
immutability its support for algebraic
data types like you yeah it's better for
to express your domain for the main
modeling you have functional patterns
it's easier to test
partly because of immutability also once
it was in which is specific
for UI developer which we will have a
look how it works it's time travel
debugger actually you can apply tools
like redux and show what your change of
your application state and time and and
web is is it functional I mean when one
of the the web workflow with web process
come F communication it's functional
transformation actually it has very low
to do with classical object oriented
approach so there are plenty of reasons
and if you are new to this and would
like to explore functional approaches I
would recommend to start with L because
this is a language specifically designed
to build user interface and when I was
searching which article I can recommend
there was a one funny quote which I
found that it was somebody who actually
was a bit pissed when he started looking
at Elm okay it's like if big eyes and
they want to probably to bring Haskell
to front and then he felt him loss when
he actually started learning more about
the language and I can understand why L
is a purely functional there strong
static types no news and partly because
of that there are no runtime exceptions
it's reactive it really fits web nature
and it compiles to JavaScript
so it's specifically designed to build
front-end web applications which is very
good to start understanding this
approach because if you take like fable
elements which we are going to look
later then you have a mixture of you
know F sharp which are also applicable
to back-end dotnet CLR and then it's
easy to sort of get lost a little bit in
in this mixture of things we should what
is available what is not with with an
you get just minimalistic set of things
which work on on front-end so L wisdom
came pattern which is now known as Model
View update
who went to meet up yesterday last night
few people there was three talks and two
of them mentioned this part and
modelview update so it's a department
which is implemented in Elm you have
model which is immutable
then true model you render view and then
messages coming from end users or maybe
from outside they going through update
which is function transformations which
transform your model into a new model so
now there is no in place changes
everything is immutable so model is
transformed in the new model and then
the loop closes so these are core
elements of a market architecture and
also of the applications that we are
going to look at you have initial state
so where you start you have view which
is a which transforms model into HTML
you have messages you update which
transforms applies messages to the model
and get a new model and also you have
optional subscriptions because you may
subscribe on some external events not
just user input will generate your
changes in your model but some something
which happens internally so typical Elm
program like at the top of elm program
looks like this you have a problem with
initialize with exist four elements and
of those subscription is optional
because your program doesn't subscribe
on anything it still drops without it so
L is fine and recommend you have a look
at it and who works mainly or partly
with dotnet but well no actually almost
everyone yeah so I still recommend you
to have a look at L if you want to if
you're getting interested but if you
want to be efficient under that platform
then actually fable and fable L mesh
this is L brought to you and actually
port it very well by tools like Visual
Studio code writer and and Visual Studio
so what is fable it's a it's a compiler
it basically compiles F sharp to
JavaScript in the end so immutable like
mmm like F sharp
it supports modern JavaScript uses Babel
at an intermediate language its type
safe and it can easily interrupt with
JavaScript you can even import other
JavaScript components and also it has
first-class agent support so you can use
it as I mentioned in various tools what
else this is not a core part of fable
but it's quite efficient like we
continue speaking about efficiency to
use fable we say will react because you
get for free all react development tools
which you can use with your fable
application and you can even import
react components so you don't need to
write some tedious code like pretty fine
JSON documents also fable supports some
additional adding some additional
libraries which wraps CSS so for me as a
developer who didn't really have great
CSS knowledge it was very helpful that I
get strongly typed CSS in my application
so I could actually I got hints about
what what is available for me and of
course mmm since we it's not like some
of popular c-sharp libraries where you
have like 10 million downloads the under
allocation okay should we try it is it
production is it enterprise really can
bring to our organization and I'm afraid
often in many development teams this
paralyzes the whole team instead of just
setting some criteria ok if
it answers this criteria see if I can do
this this this we start using it
people start sinking and actually I was
there I was okay I'm the first one to
probably to introduce variable an
organization should I do it and well I'm
external consultant what will they think
about it for me the turning point was
about one year ago I went to some off am
day and there was a talk actually was
lightning talk from a developer probably
half of my age he was like in his
mid-twenties units per Dow he was in
turn actually at the time of this report
on this project hide by NSB now that I
change the name but it's Norwegian state
railroad so it's as enterprises as
Enterprise can be and there was stuck
with you know it's not sufficient not
efficient front-end development and they
decided to give it a try to bring L and
now actually and they core all their Co
web solutions they're they're powered by
by L of course it's also it's s very
good about management actually was a
keen to give this youngsters to give it
a try and then they succeeded and then
for me it was like very enlightening
back ok now I need to to try it and then
I just spent two three long days decided
I will ask for forgiveness later and you
know it was surprisingly much which I
was able to achieve just within
literally hours which actually I'm going
to share with you in a slightly yes
simplified version so what we have we
have event journals in our organization
we this is our table storage we receive
plenty of events from different external
services all the time we need to store
it in our tables and blobs source so
it's nothing
really and lightning there you know it's
just data of course but is it impossible
if something happens this is an
important impossible to use just by
running query again through this storage
Explorer because you need to be quick
you need to be really efficient into
analyzing what's what's going on
so next step for us was that okay let's
make a function okay we made it our
function now we can use curl or postman
to to get this stuff but it's still you
know if if you have a small crisis if
some news clip is not published you have
to have full picture within seconds
basically no we have to do something
better like that so oh this is actually
better this is one of intermediate
versions written in F sharp and which as
you can see we can select some journal
we're done we can select some results
get some payload it's probably good to
prettify this JSON but we'll get back to
it so I mean if we can achieve this
within a short time it's probably worth
doing this so okay what we started we
have some journals we need to be able to
query them by interval by document ID
okay to operate more quickly we need
some predefined searches like search by
our by for hours and so on okay then we
get some results and we should be able
to click on the result and let you get
some payload and next thing would be to
prettify it so if we manage to get it to
get such front-end within a reasonably
short time definitely fine
so now I have a plan so we have a real
catch f sharp model type and some
related types that will present
application state then we will create
messages define messages which actually
transform this model and we create HTML
page
which we will use fable react component
and then first we will make as
minimalistic as possible no sisters are
also be ugly but it will work maybe if
you can convince some of back-end
developers but I guess it won't convince
any client let me add some CSS and we
try to do as minimum as little as
possible
without typing any you know magic
strings whatever some CSS wrapper gives
us then we will find some problems which
we want to fix and we will see how
actually at that time we are able to fix
it and in the end assuming we have time
we have a look how we can actually bring
wrapped components and two into that so
let's get started
I'm switching now for the rest of the
talk to Visual Studio code so yeah so
this is Visual Studio code with
extension which is called aya night no
no tonight Frank our night of sharp yeah
so that's what what you need to run your
application also here in the terminal
I'm running let me show you what I'm
running there the readme and px web
active server so I have a development
server whenever Visual Studio detects
that I changed something it will just
you compile it and then I get immediate
feedback so let's start with model so
yeah
so we have some event sources and this
words look like Greek probably but it's
just name of some internal service for
example radio are keep it anonymous try
to archive subtitles of the special
potion actually it's news clips and so
so we have collections of these sources
and then these are so called
discriminated union in a sharp which mmm
looks like enumerate and c-sharp but
it's more powerful because you can
actually specify the types of each case
so you have search mode you have search
interval you have such startles you have
time zone choice between UTC and local
and like the service event is so called
a record type it's a it's what event
contains so it looks pretty much like a
like a class and yeah if we get back is
a JSON or XML or some unknown content
then there are some search results app
settings and this is our model
so our model container consists of our
application settings search mode search
interval ID of current document like
from time to time time zone selected
collections of documents search starters
so it's pretty simple to define it and I
guess even if you're not familiar with F
sharp having knowledge of basically any
programming language will bring you
quite quickly into ability to define
these models so next we're going to
define messages we need to convert to
transform models based on what messages
forget okay so we have one application
starts it's all application settings
every single synchronous so settings can
either be loaded or they can fail so we
have like three messages here loading
loaded failed search options we can
search by ID by interval and there are
some predefined interval searches one
hour four hours just to make search
quicker to specify that then controls
changes what can change on the screen
also quite straightforward you see
everything is discriminated Union so
it's a it so called some type so
either-or so every message is one of and
only one of those types and then
in the end when we search search can
complete successfully or fail so there
are three messages for that also
messages if we want if we loaded search
results and want to load particular
payload then we load content loading of
content can also either fail or succeed
so you see it's just a 30 something
lines of code so now we have model now I
have messages and next thing we need to
define is we need to we need to define
update because we need to react on
messages so what happens when we receive
some message the easiest is when we have
a message that just changes something on
the screen for example program ID
changed what we do we define model with
ID it's not that we changing model in
place no we creating a new model it's
very important a model is immutable but
we create a new one and when we create a
new one we copy original one but set ID
to the new value and the same Danann
means that we done with no more commands
needed it's it's typical when we react
on user input like change something in
the model with done changing we done for
example search interval for hours new
model will search interval set to two
hours and you see I have intelligence
for everything thanks to this an ID
exemption when we start search things
get more complicated but not very
complicated we start search so we start
search with fetch URL and we specify act
a handler for completed search and for
failed search and with if you start
search if I drill into start search
actually what we do we just sent a HTTP
request to some URL so this is actually
where Interop with JavaScript you see
fetch us this is actually we are this is
Interop fable goals underneath using
JavaScript Interop and get get
HTTP requests but it's it's not really
actually interesting for us as
developers because we focus on our
domain this is no this is just plumbing
HTTP call so this is basically how
update works so last thing which we need
is is a view and the simplest view which
we can come up with is just plain HTML
to you you see we have some dibs we have
some tables buttons handlers and so on
but this is not pure sh t ml actually
it's a part of Fable react interpreter
because all those are act elements and
advantage of this is that it gives us
strong strong typing so actually this is
how it's done interact and you don't
need to use table react you can actually
specify plain HTML but it's easy because
you have intellisense support and your
compilation will fail if you specify
something wrong here so you see it's
just you know 150 lines of code and if
you run it so you see something like
this which is just plain HTML so we can
for example I want to search new crease
crease new scripts search ok yeah and if
I click on some actually I get I get
asked on to some JSON yeah well I have a
friend who is developer who would say
that this is actually done and this is
as good as it is because technically on
the communication level everything is
done everything is working properly but
who would pay money for this application
right I wouldn't do it either so of
course this is observed this is known as
speaking about like on behalf of the
customer we have to make it somewhat
better so what can we do we need to
apply some CSS but we don't want to know
CSS so what we can do we can take some
of available CSS wrappers for for
sharp one of them it's called Puma it's
very well documented for example let me
show you like okay I'm going to elements
but yeah so here's how you can make some
buttons and everyone to view code this
is how this is a code just fine - you
fool man it it gives a strong typing and
as a consequence intellisense of the top
of Puma which is free open-source CSS
library which is opinionated like you
you have to sort of like the layout look
and feel of buttons parts of UI code
that they they give you but it's it's
it's like this is most of I think most
of CSS and then for us if I'm not happy
with this particular CSS library we can
actually switch to another one there are
there was a growing number of wrappers
of course we can use directly as I CSS
but what I would like to do now is to
change HTML you to minimalistic form of
view so we're using Fuma so let me show
how it looks full of you it's a it's
actually just slightly different than
what we had but here you will see
something like yeah color is light for
example and so boom defines their own
meaning of what is light is light okay
is light is link color is is great light
and so so so there are some opinion two
choices which Fulmer does for us which
we choose here like button is full weeds
actually I don't know what is full miss
I did I didn't know it okay maybe it
means that a button should be
for full width of this container yes it
is yeah so and then also we can even
make it responsive we can specify that
certain size of screen give different
size of text this is interesting that's
let's try this
so if original HTML view was about 100 i
think 150 lines this full of you we are
more detailed also here we specify
actually I'm sorry I first this is one I
wanted to show you next we start this
first with minimal for view because
which doesn't support responsive yeah
because it's just 50 lines or 60 lines
larger than original so we we use Fulmer
but not sort of advanced part of Fulmer
we just add as little Fuma as we can so
it will give us some nice look of
application so we change HTML view to
minimal form of you yeah yes so it's
your compiled now and if you go back to
our application actually it's changed
and it looks definitely better than the
original plain HTML so if you want to
search for news clips yeah it gives some
results if I click on result it gives
you know some payload
well we it's probably going right
direction but there are certain things
that will stop us from calling it like
complete we can sell it to the client
for example you know this is a long list
how can i scroll no that's not good so i
have to scroll the whole thing you know
i want to be able to scroll here also if
thinking
out being with Puma is responsive but if
I try to change the size actually
actually it reflects change of screen
but what we see here one hour for 20
hours you know it's it's not really good
so we need to to do something with it
so there are several things that we want
to change and that's a good test are we
able actually to go down to CSS level
and start changing these things and for
me as a back-end developer it was a very
good moment because when I was looking
at clean HTML page I didn't know where
to start
I mean CSS it's it's several thousand
definitions and how that shows right now
I'm very focused I want to find how to
add a scroll bar vertical scroll bar to
my element I want to change my
responsive use so it will properly
reflect when we resize the window
so going from minimal form of you to
form of you it's a it's slightly larger
we will find here then okay here
actually I'm very specific about
defining four different screen sizes I
want to define different column sizes
and Fuma and boom also comes with some
predefined choices like is food is
one-third is 1/4 so of course you can
start doing it in in pixels eventually
but in most cases it's actually it's a
good choices which you are given it's
just to find the one which suits you
also you see now I started using a magic
strings this comes from CSS I started
learning CSS ok world rap war break word
okay this is my actual vertical
scrollbar
so this is I found it actually I can
actually
and vertical scrollbar to my element by
specifying overflow why odor and which a
scroll bar if the the size of of control
growth more than 96% of size of the
container
so actually one by one I was able to
eliminate all the defects of the
original minimalistic approach so if you
look now we will change minimum we go to
some of you you form of you yeah so
that's yeah but you see the three we
have now scroll bar here yeah also if we
resize then you see now it's it's
changed from 24 hours to 24h yeah
actually it is you see they still it's
not good I need to pay more attention
but it's a sort of now I can force on
this part where exactly it should change
change according and yeah and also I
would like to provide but actually we
are getting there we see now that we can
actually the develop as powerful front
end as we would like to it's just that
we will need to eventually learn some
elements of CSS but it's very good to
get started with something that gives
you decent look and feel so now let's
make this nicer this Jason since we are
just compiling or fable compiles
everything into JavaScript we and we use
fable reactant Europe so if they look at
I think it's update utilities
[Music]
and know of you assessing its view
chills yeah here you see prettify Jason
what we do the importing react Jason you
I just found some react component which
beautifies Jason and are the same I did
for XML react XML viewer so I initialize
it with some initial value which fits my
application and then what happened then
full my view is components it gets
recompiled yeah let's search for
something yeah and so you see is this is
just integration with react components
straight from f-sharp application and
the actual integration
it's a one-liner all five liners yeah
and speaking about a react now all
[Music]
powerful react development tools
actually available for us so if we I
think I have here Redux so let's click
on it this is time travel debugger so I
can actually click and it gives me my
you know F sharp object F sharp types
compiled into into JavaScript C
collection change okay let's play it
yeah and then change something from
potion to ride your kite yeah and click
it again collection change you see the
former value was Tolson its new clips
and new values radio coverage right
rider key and this is thanks to
immutability because you have immutable
model so all changes they're just
instances of new model and so you if you
something as goes wrong you just play
back your commands and you see exactly
what changed for what reasons and like
what you need to do with that and you
can actually
save this history and send it to other
developers as I will have a look so you
see it it's it's quite efficient
actually to work with strongly typed
languages that generate JavaScript which
are which is react friendly you can just
immediately take advantage of all tools
available to you so speaking about
source code size we actually had a
legacy web app which nobody loved to
rock with it was some other back-end
developer like myself who wrote it using
C Scharf mixture of JavaScript HTML
which was more than thousand lines
it was mixture of c-sharp HTML
javascript and of course some CSS and
everything now it's turned with actually
with with more powerful functionality
because now we have this pretty pretty
fight used which we didn't have before
now just seven F sharp files you saw
that how short these files are in
totally about 400 lines of types and
business logic and almost the same
number of lines of views and view logic
and this is you know you have to have
these views so it's a mmm and now
actually we have few people in our
organization who actually started
working with fable knife sharp and they
they love doing this work because it's a
much more comfortable to work with such
codebase and with such tools so this is
more or less what I had in mind to tell
you and when I have talks sometimes I
sing songs about topic of my
presentation just so you can memorize it
better and so for this talk I wrote
a song that is formally known as
O'Carroll by British group smoking which
which is called Oh
table so if audio works then you can
sing along I was a functional boy and I
really enjoyed transformations and the
mutable state and I shoot myself that's
the whole front end to something else
and that is not my fate
but then a suddenly knew that there was
something new and at first I just
glutton billing at the dried client out
in my normally a shark all my goodness
what a relief to hold back and tusks and
this wholesale stuff I have to see space
and they were function price and later
strongly type I felt I wish immutable
paradise Oh fable you got me ready for
the Hall of Fame because you showed me
run you a on writing a box all day
or fatal nobody's done it before when
you open the door or fail we can do it
some more
I'm still back into spec this table
el-medina secret super front end and our
night till it sells heats the bouncy
assess rock improvement roads all the
sand and what about devil Street it will
never believe me producer my functional
code he disobey will compile a vector
change supply and more than helper this
is my God's o Babel you give up your ad
for the Hall of Fame because you show me
a brand new way on writing web apps
called AAA o fable nobody's done it
before
I mean you open the door
o fail we can do it some more
you'd more of this platform madness
tomorrow it's after party with two hours
of IT parodies so I your old bike it'll
be dropped group hope you enjoy my day
is a crop circle star o Babel the Hall
of Fame because the show me a brand new
way on rights away about scold AAA of
Babel nobody's done it before
I mean you open the door oh oh you got
me ready for the Hall of Fame because it
showed me a run you way I'm writing web
apps called AAA Oh fable nobody's done
it before
Khomeini of all from the door or favor
we can do some more Oh fable baby
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you so this is what Allah had who
is more interested into giving
functional programming on front-end a
try than before this hour thank you I
appreciate that and we still have some
time for questions if you have yeah
otherwise you can yeah the question the
question was about interaction with
JavaScript promises well all calls there
they must be a thing so it doesn't
support like no nothing course you can't
sort of you don't have model dialogue
sort of and it's you can use both
promises when one - I think my mmm ok
yeah so you can there are two different
ways to communicate with back and
underneath it's using promises using I
think which is closer to dotnet
developers so there and then under the
hood that slightly differently
implemented but they both are
synchronous so you you have to have a
handler own like own result and also
like own error this is the proper way of
doing it more questions
yeah well as long as you use yeah it's
enabled sort of by default as long as
you use fable react because you don't
need to use react because fables just
just compiles whatever F M F sharp you
have into JavaScript and it's not all
this able to compile it because yeah of
course if you start using WCF in your
code then you will get a compilation
fail saying that you know this is not
supported so the subset it's a support
compile to JavaScript and then as long
as you use fable react then yes it you
can get Redux more questions yeah then
thank you again and enjoy the rest of
the conference
[Applause]